je me vois les pompiers qui cherche
quelque chose il ne trouve pas je savais
que mes deux collègues et on s'apprête à
rentrer dans l'hôtel et puis j'en
entends un qui dit fête ça y est je les
trouvais et donc je me retourne pour
voir et il y en a un des deux son
compagnon qui prend une clé pour
justement faire mais le tuyau de gaz et
l'explosion bas je pense qu'il a pas
réussi à faire mieux je suis au parce
que ça a pété dans la rue et voilà donc
j'ai vu mourir devant mes yeux baal et
en os atterrir sur le sol et le feu
venir sur moi et j'ai vu une boule de
feu les vaisseaux ouais j'y ai pas perdu
connaissance et j'ai tout vu de toute la
scène donc tous les jours j'ai ces
images là
vous allez ouvrir les yeux j'ai cru que
c'était la fin pour vous exactement et
je la seule chose que je demandais
c'était qu'on me donne un téléphone pour
dire à mes parents au revoir
comprenez pas tout de suite l'étendue
des blessures non les premiers temps
je vois je touche mon visage je touche
mon ventre et je me dis bon dieu merci à
rien je vois mon poignet qui avait
explosé mais je me dis bon c'est que ça
ça va et donc en fait le brouillard par
la fumée par et je vois que j'ai plus de
jambes au dessus j'ai que mon squelette
j'ai plus les objets plus les muscles
j'ai plus rien il me restait que la peau
en bas et plus le brouillard par puis je
découvre que mon pied brook est souvent
une porte et bah j'ai plus rien ma jambe
gauche y avait plus rien mon tibia droit
y avait plus rien du tout j'étais en
sous-vêtements à 6 à crier à l'aide et
personne n'était là enfin vous avez des
clients de l'hôtel qui me marcher dessus
avec leur valise et qui partent et enfin
me regarder et j'étais désespéré je leur
demandais d'appeler les pompiers mais
par peur ils sont tous enfuis
donc je prends pas ma 45 minutes j'étais
assise par terre et me vider de mon sens
et à me dire bah quand est-ce qu'on
allait me trouvais
j'avais suivi plus de 40 opérations 41
et la janvier je retourne par la 42e ou
disais que vous ne pourriez plus marcher
on m'a dit oui les trois premiers mois
on m'a dit que c'était fauteuil roulant
avis que baye avait plus d'espoir quand
mes jambes que c'était fini voilà qu'ils
avaient pratiquement tout fait mais
c'était impossible qu'on dise que je
remarche avait plus personne ne peut
décider à ma place donc c'est pas
possible d'être battu je me suis battu
ça a été dur mais
aujourd'hui vous vous l'avez dit avoir
pensé à ça tous les jours ça reste un
traumatisme à vie
et ce qui rajoute à ce traumatisme c'est
qu'aujourd'hui pour l'instant ces
statues coule au niveau des
indemnisations il avait reçu aucune
indemnisation de la mairie paris qui est
mise en examen ou du syndic de
copropriété aussi qu'ils n'ont personne
n'a voulu nous verser quoi que ce soit
et on ne demande pas une indemnisation
bas pour aller en vacances ou quoi que
ça c'est juste que on est à trois ans
que l'épée pourquoi ils sont des
plaintes au tribunal que des procédés
des procès n'est pas encore là mais à
une désespère tease et donc ça fait un
an qu'on connait les personnes mises en
examen mais qu'on leur demande de l'aide
moi je comprends pas je vais vous dire
je comprends pas en fait que ça au bout
de trois ans ville il ya rien qui ait
bougé on va entendre le lot leurs
témoignages dossier a décidé dans un
instant mais c'est incroyable la mairie
de paris elle doit faire quelque chose
je suis désolé je suis témoin la prépa
pouvait pas faire traîner comme ça une
affaire aussi grave vous avez
entièrement raison l'enquète patiner
très longue ce qui se passait comme la
mairie et mise en examen elle a demandé
pour homicide 1l à demander des
contre-expertises et donc du coup
jusqu'à il ya trois jours elle refusait
de débloquer des fonds parce que elle
pensait que ça allait être une
reconnaissance de sa culpabilité
donc ils ont tout bloqué et ils ont
laissé pendant des mois cesser ces
pauvres gens qui ont subi des menaces
elles obligées de payer elle même ses
opérations au 41 rue la lavande écoute
larible qu'on rendez compte ce que ça la
bande des terribles tels gens mais là un
moment à un moment un moment faut même
si quitte à ce que la mairie de paris
avance l'argent bien celui ci voilà même
si derrière il ya des assurances il ya
des choses qui joue il ya peut-être
peut-être qu'ils sont pas responsables
mais au moins qu'elles avancent l'argent
pour l'instant aux lieux anne hidalgo
dieu de faire des travaux partout et
nous faire chier gens mais sans rigoler
non excusez moi c'est inadmissible quand
je vois ça c'est inadmissible mais si on
attend qu'elle attende et la mairie de
paris fait recours sur recours pour pas
plaisir et étonnement c'est inadmissible
désolé ce qui fut toujours dans cette
histoire c'est que l ai fait croire
qu'il lui fallait une loi pour
indemniser des victimes qui la maire de
paris la maire de paris dont elle avait
écrit un courrier à jean castex il ya un
an pour demander une loi etc en fait
elle a fait perdre du temps alors que
plusieurs fois elle a débloqué des fonds
ne semble jamais avoir demandé l'avis du
gouvernement et nous comme par hasard
alors qu'on ait des victimes de qu'on a
besoin de ça pour nos soins de prise en
charge les psychologues c'est à rien pas
un centime